and because the NBA season is ramping up
there has been a lot of reporting on
what we can expect as they resume play
our friend from Bleacher Report Taylor
Brooks has been right there reporting on
this very issue you've had a ton of
insight Taylor as we welcome you to game
time I'd like to just start off right
away with the Kyrie Irving sentiments
how he has been voicing his opinion and
leading a player coalition yeah that is
one thing that every single player I've
discussed has talked about how Kyrie has
become a leader really during this time
and and during this movement always
voicing exactly what he feels and what
he thinks that players can do to to
progress the social justice movement and
keep talks about actionable items he has
definitely been affirmed in his stance
that they are there are a lot of pros to
not playing not going to Orlando that is
something he has been consistent with
throughout this whole time the report
that I disputed however was the one that
came out from New York Daily News which
was that he was in his group chat and
proposed that the Nets start a new
league through talking to a bunch of
them that is not what happened The Daily
News has since come out and clarified
that report but it hasn't really been
that great right now in the group chat
Kyrie has actually since left that group
chat due to that report that he feels
was misconstrued but Kyrie absolutely
has been a main voice in this and I
think will continue to be until there's
some sort of result yeah I want to go
back to that point with Kyrie Dwight
Howard has come out do you think the
players are really starting to now open
up their minds get all the information
they need so they can make a better
decision as Adam Silver's come out or
some of the new guidelines yeah for sure
I mean definitely the ones that I've
talked to and there's a better idea of
what the bubble is gonna look like I was
joking with the player saying you know
this is like summer camp you know you're
gonna be with all your friends you gotta
be bugged out there's gotta be some
activities you know the original concern
was is this bubble really a bubble right
they felt like there were people going
in and now how safe are we going to be
and that is a very very real concern you
know there was a report saying that
Donovan Mitchell had discussed you know
we need to discuss well now that we have
kind of gotten a sneak peek into this
memo it's been widely reported several
elements especially when you talk about
the safety protocol as it relates to
kovat 19 have the players expressed I
don't want to use the word relief but
maybe a better understanding and comfort
level because they've now seen the
protocols laid out yeah I have talked to
two players who said that they have a
better idea of what the bubble is now
and that probably is because more things
were laid out because in all honesty I
think a lot of people had questions
about how this bubble is going to work
when there wasn't as much information
but now there's more and people are able
to make sound decisions and one thing
that has really been stressed on these
calls is that the decision is yours
meaning it's going to be up to players
to decide what they want to do and you
are going to end up taking all the
information that you can to make the
sound decision so the more information
that comes out from the league about
protocol the more people will be able to
make decisions that best fit them in
terror speaking a little decision have
to ask you now as a media member what
are one of your two concerns that if you
can invite to the bubble or go to the
bubble what would be your concerns yeah
I mean making sure everyone in there is
tested I think is it's very key making
sure that those tests are available and
ready and we can always know you know
the coronavirus level within the bubble
I'm nervous about people going in and
out of the bubble that's definitely a
concern of mine and also I don't know if
this is you know directly about the
virus but you wonder okay are you going
to be able to see people you know I
think about the guys they have families
like oh are you gonna be able to see
your wife your children you know if I'm
in this bubble what am I gonna be doing
will I get to see my family that's
that's definitely a concern but I
understand that in essence for the
bubble to be a bubble you have to stay
in there and people can't go in and out
but that's something that is it's
definitely a bit of a concern of mine
and what ways can you really you know
police this area because at the end of
the day people are going to be people
we're all human I'm so intrigued by all
of this I am really looking forward to
not just the return to action but how
all of these things will be implemented
we'll all be watching it very closely
but Taylor while I have you here you
know I have to brag about your new show
you have a new long-form show coming up
on bleacher report your series will
start this Friday please tell us all
about it I'm very excited oh thank you
so much I'm really excited for it too as
you said it starts on Friday
DeMar DeRozan is guest number one and
when I was looking at you know
everything happening with this super
important movement the black lives
matter movement the social justice
movement a lot of the talk was about
where we are right now and I felt like
something that was missing was how we
got here and the emotions that many
people feel right now what has happened
in their life that has led them to feel
so strongly about the injustice is that
we see right now so the series centers
around two questions which is the first
question when did you realize that being
black meant something different from
being white and the last question is how
do you define America and through
stories and anecdotes
they are discussing how their life
affects how they view things now and
it's really been incredibly moving for
me like I said demar derozan is the
first episode we also have one coming up
with Matt Barnes JJ reddick Malcolm
Jenkins and I just applaud how real and
authentic and emotional they were
throughout these I I walked away from
each
I'm just feeling more connected to them
but also this movement and the emotions
that everybody is facing and I hope
that's what everybody thinks as well
when they watch them love it Taylor
rooks
we are excited congratulations on the
new show and we are very much looking
forward to it yeah I appreciate you guys
having me stay healthy